but i had machine gun kelly on here the
first time he was all [ __ ] up from
some beer pong party you threw
how do you throw a beer punk party
he didn't come out to utah did he
um no machine gun oh this is in lh you
got some kind of pad out in la right
well it's just
it here we're kind of nomadic so when
you have your beer pong league you have
an actual league right
in the works
in the works and he and this must have
been some [ __ ] party because this guy
you know there's a guy smokes a lot of
weed and certainly can drink
he was all [ __ ] up i'm so hungover
it's insane were you out last night i
was playing on like a beer pong
tournament with post malone i'm like
what's the deal like who's in this
league and how do you get in and how
does it get started and how do you win i
mean what what's going on
you win by getting drunk i guess right
right it's the best game in the world
and so where do you have this like if
you're at a studio you'll say you'll
call up a guy like machine gun kelly and
say hey we're doing some beer pong
tonight everybody come on over
well we filmed this so we had a
a section of filming and we were um kind
of just hanging out and every we had
guests come over we had um you know
everybody just come and hang out and
play some beer pong and and see who won
and i performed terribly on the show but
um
i'm way better
if you ever want to play i i got a shot
i got a shot right here reaching out to
you you know and it's right in that cup
right next